in afghanistan there were widespread
celebrations yesterday on the one year
anniversary of the taliban retaking
control of the country for many women
and girls there it has been a very very
tough year mts tayab has a story of one
woman's restricted life under taliban
rule he's in kabul that's the capital of
afghanistan with more on that part of
the story mts a lot of people worried
this was going to happen good morning to
you
absolutely right gail good morning to
you all across afghanistan women and
girls continue to fight for even the
most basic rights we spoke to one 25
year old activist a warning now some of
the details of her story may be hard to
hear
oh my heart
intelligence officer started banging on
her door the women's rights activist
filmed the ordeal on her phone
broadcasting to the world as she begged
for help
we met paryani at a safe house as she
tells us how she and her three sisters
were arrested that january night
the only weapon i had was my camera i
knew i had to speak out despite how
dangerous the situation was
i did it so that i could show the world
what the taliban are really like what
kind of group they are and how they seek
to forcefully silence women you know
how long were you in prison for
well for about one month
and how were you treated
cruelly
they treated me disgracefully
they tortured me using cables pipes and
whips
as they were torturing me they would
record it it was a terrifying experience
says she was arrested because the
taliban thought she was organizing
protests around the country against
their latest decree that the islamic
head scarf or hijab was now compulsory
stories like paryani's aren't isolated
according to amnesty international the
taliban have quote decimated the rights
of women and girls in afghanistan
through a campaign of harassment
arbitrary detentions and torture
abdul-gahar balki is the taliban
spokesman for the ministry of foreign
affairs we spoke to
women's rights activists
they talk about torture
waterboarding and other forms of abuse
we absolutely reject it we do not engage
in torture waterboarding or other
practices that the united states
has or is engaged in across the world
so these women are lying
if indeed their cases were true the
government would take the appropriate
actions to address them paryani says
while she was in prison there were times
when she contemplated suicide
every time i thought about taking my own
life i'd think about the future of my
three sisters if i'm dead what will
happen to them
but the taliban were forced to release
me they couldn't kill me because i
recorded my arrest
what do you think the world needs to
know about the taliban
today that the taliban have money and
resources
that they have food and they have drink
but the people of afghanistan they are
drowning in their own blood
now paryani tells us that she will
continue to fight for afghan women and
girls
no matter the risks
nate
mts
eye-opening and incredibly incredibly
powerful reporting in afghanistan thank
you so much